a coming out does not have to be
surprising
to be meaningful
[Music]
hello there folks I am here to talk to
you about
shurigatwa and no not for his part in a
show that I'm not going to bring up
because unless I'm doing a review I'm
not going to talk about that show but if
you follow this channel you know why
shooting godwa is on my radar but he's
known at this point for a number of
things including the biggest movie of
the year so he's doing quite well for
himself he had a cover shoot for L
magazine as part of Elle's style Awards
because katwa has become fairly well
known for his looks at things like Red
Carpet Events he's
quite hard to miss
and there were some really interesting
things that were said
inside of that L magazine including
His official coming out now that might
strike some people as confusing I
suspect a fair number of you who are
aware of godwa assumed he was already
out actually that was such a broad
assumption that I saw the uh the fact
that he was cast as a lead in a show
that I talk about a lot touted is like
being the first queer person in that
part I made a short at the time that
I've now since unlisted because he has
confirmed that he is not CIS had a Rowan
is therefore queer we'll get into the
specifics of what he said in a minute
but I did at the time put out a short
saying hey
um he's actually gone way out of his way
to not say how he identifies either in
terms of gender or sexuality so like
don't claim that he is this thing when
he is very much not said that he is he's
never said that he's anything well
now he has which is why I unlisted that
short it's no longer relevant it's now
completely outdated and uh inaccurate
for what we now know
some people might be content to just
file under
the week's least surprising news
is queer
wow I'm so shocked look at my shocked
face
but the thing is the fact that he came
out at all given how he has approached
things up to this point and some of the
specific things that he said when he did
so
I actually think are really worth
talking about particularly in light of
some of the things that I touched on
when I did a video
um a little while ago talking about the
pressures that queer performers who are
not comfortable being publicly out might
feel to come out in order to avoid
criticism of things like queerbaiting so
if you want to see that video it's there
and I even brought godwa up in that
though he was by no means the main focus
it's interesting to talk about a figure
who has in no way ever really hid his
queerness but has also never really
talked openly about it and even here in
this interview with Al he doesn't really
not fully it gets mentioned almost as a
passing detail later on now
mentioned in the article later on
whether or not it was said late into the
interview we actually don't know it's
perfectly possible for the journalists
who actually wrote this up to put these
in any order because it wasn't formatted
as a question answer question answer
question answer interview it was talking
about sitting down and having the
conversation and so building a narrative
it's possible that he actually said this
early on instead of saying it towards
the end like it's oh and by the way you
know last thing but that is how it is
presented in the article and we'll get
to what he specifically said about his
sense of queerness in a little bit
um this is where I will note if you take
issue with that word because I knew I
know some members of the lgbtqia plus
Community do
um I'm using it because it's the word he
used I mean it's a word I'm also
comfortable with but I do recognize at
this point that it is not a universal
word in terms of people's Comfort level
and it's one that I'm very careful about
applying to specific people unless I
know that's a term they're comfortable
using and God was demonstrated that not
only is he comfortable with it appears
to be his preferred term but again we
will come back to that he talks a bit
about his sense of fashion saying flat
out how empowering he feels of course it
is there's something about being in a
courses that makes me feel so masculine
he talked about his View and approach
towards gendered clothing and how he
doesn't like labels
cloves are to play with I love seeing
men in women's clothing there doesn't
need to be a label I believe that fully
that's why I don't like to label myself
and I don't owe it to anyone
that quote actually feels a little bit
pointed because he has avoided labels
for himself up to this point which might
bring one to wonder why it is he does do
eventually and we will get to it a
confirmation of being queer in this
article and in this conversation and
while I am trying very hard to not
put my projected Notions and thoughts
into Gotham's mouth or try and
um parse his thought process because I
have no business doing that
I do think there is something that he
says that gives an interesting context
to why this might be the time that he
chose to openly talk about this and
particularly he brings up the character
he was best known for before the more
recent stuff he was cast in
um this year and last and
he talks about playing an openly queer
character in what became a well-watched
and well-regarded show
and having done that for as long as he
did over the course of Four Seasons
really seemed to bring to him the
importance of representation
he's so Fierce and unashamed it was
healing for me and great for people to
see themselves represented it taught me
the importance of representation
it's so powerful and necessary
and that's interesting for him to talk
about because earlier he talked about
some of his own insecurities about his
sense of place just in general when he
said this
inside it's such a mess I have so much
imposter syndrome I have so many
insecurities I like to make other people
feel happy so there's less focus on me I
become this loud figure that's cracking
jokes all the time it comes across as
confidence but at the heart of it it's
not real confidence is something I have
to work on daily
so it doesn't seem unreasonable to
assume given these quotes that
playing that part and playing somebody
so unabashed in who they are and not
holding back for anybody
gave him a sense of understanding of the
importance of that and maybe gave him
some more confidence by proxy in a way
because what he describes that's kind of
low-key imposter syndrome I actually
kind of talked about a little bit myself
fairly recently granted I was talking
about imposter syndrome mostly in terms
of my work and what I do here but I did
in that video Touch on the idea that it
had leaked into my perception of myself
as a queer person as a trans person that
I shouldn't use certain labels because
that doesn't feel like I'm deserving of
those labels for one reason or another
again you can check out that video for
more on that but I think there's
probably a little bit something else
that drove his coming out because the
interviewer brings up the idea and I I
really want to be very clear I don't
think the interviewer was presenting
this as something for him to address
directly but more talking about it as a
thing that gets brought up when people
who are not cisgender white heterosexual
actual able-bodied and traditionally
attractive get cast in Major roles there
is often conversations about
tokenism about pandering to a certain
kind of audience about as the
um interviewer put it box ticking and
again I don't think she brought that up
because she was actually making the
suggestion herself that gosh what being
cast in anything is some form of box
taking but she did bring up the subject
and that seemed to spark actual anger in
him
first of all you don't know anything
about me secondly take boxes
people need to be seen what are
you going to do tell the same stories
have the same people fronting things for
all of eternity representation and
inclusivity and branching out it
enriches us all
how embarrassing you people with your
tiny mindsets open a book look out the
window and then off again I don't
mean to project but I don't think it's
an unfair assumption for me to put out
there that he's probably been hearing
some version of
you were put in this part just to tick a
box for his entire career and probably
before because he was probably seeing
those conversations happen around anyone
else who diverged from those traits that
I mentioned earlier like him
so I suspect that that little Outburst
was kind of a long time coming it's
probably maybe not something that he's
been repressing and holding back but
speaking of someone who has felt
similar frustrations at hearing any
instance of inclusion being immediately
questioned and undermined and devalued
and presented as if it has no inherent
worth it's just there to be forced
diversity it's an anger I understand
very very well even though I cannot
relate to all of it being
a very white person as I am
I can still absolutely relate to what he
said in that moment a lot
but that brings us now finally
to what he actually said that I would
consider to be is coming out
he describes going to a pride event and
seeing a woman that looked like his
auntie now gatwa is Scottish he grew up
there but he was born in Rwanda and he
has ties and connections to that world
that culture those people
and he was kind of shocked to see
someone that looked so much like the
people from his life
and he ended up striking up a
conversation with her and she confessed
to him to not even be entirely sure why
she was at the pride event because she
didn't
she had she didn't have a label
but she just felt like she should be
there even though she didn't really know
why and gotwa shared this
I had never met another random person
before I thought I was the only one in
the world
and again not to project
more meaning or a thought process that
he may or may not have had but
I have to imagine that an experience
like that of finding someone
with a similar background to him who is
queer
was enough of an eye-opening moment that
along with having played some of the
parts that he's played it shored up the
importance of representation to him I
feel like that very much certainly comes
across in the way the article is
formatted
again I want to be careful about The
Narrative of the article versus actually
assuming exactly what God was intent was
because ultimately while this article is
quoting him it is not written by him so
I I want to be careful about how I
present all this
but then there's that word
queer
it is fascinating to me
that shooting
a man who has just flatly never answered
questions about his sexuality or gender
identity prior to this
has come out
with the broadest most umbrella term
available
again I know some people's discomfort
with the word but part of the value of
queer at least to me
is that it is Broad it is far-reaching
in many ways it encompasses the entire
community
and it does not require a more specific
label
if you either don't want to give it
or aren't sure what it is yet
for a long time before I came out as
gender fluid before I found that term
I identified as a cross-dresser a
cisgender cross-dresser at that
I didn't feel like I was cisgender but I
didn't feel like I fit what I understood
to be the definitions of trans
so when I found something that fit me it
meant a lot and I embraced it pretty
quickly but
despite the fact that I would present
and talk about myself as though I were
just a cross-dresser
that never
fully felt right
it did a little bit in my early 20s But
as time went on I'm like this isn't
right but I can't find something else
that's why terms like queer are so
wonderful
I didn't know what I was for a long time
but I knew I wasn't straight
and I knew I wasn't CIS
I knew I was queer
and while I just go with gender fluid
now and it fits me very well part of the
beauty of queer
is that it allows you to be able to say
whatever I am
whether it's a case of I don't know or
it's shifting or I haven't settled and
fully found myself or whether it's a
matter of the specifics of my life or
not your business it at least enables
you to say okay you know cisgender and
heterosexual heterosexual
yeah I'm not that
and that's enough
that's enough
to be part of this community to be a
source of representation
to be
queer
all you have to do is not be straight
and cisgender
you don't have to know exactly what you
are or even if you know you don't have
to tell people ultimately it's not their
business if they don't know you in a
setting where it actually matters and
understand those settings are few and
far between unless you are trying to
build an incredibly close and often
intimate relationship with someone
ultimately the specifics of their
sexuality and gender identity are truly
none of your business
and he has every right to keep those
specifics to him assuming that he knows
what they are he may not he also might
everything about how he has talked about
this and that little Outburst as well
and bringing up the fact that stuff is
not your business and I don't owe you
the answers because he doesn't
but recognizing that he does not owe
anybody
including to be fair the rest of the
queer Community he does not owe us
the details of his life and his identity
him embracing the term queer is
Meaningful to us because of his
prominence and just being visible and
even as he said how important
representation is
but we are not owed that information
but us not being owed
that information does not mean that he
also has to make some kind of principle
stance of I will never tell anybody the
decision to come out in any capacity in
highly specific details or in Broad
overarching umbrella terms like queer
that decision lies only
with the person
whom is speaking about themselves
they are the only ones who have any
business deciding what will be known
about them
and if they say at some point it's none
of your business and I don't want to
tell you they're not obligated to keep
that forever they can decide later to
give some information they can decide to
be specific they can decide to be vague
but what I have found fascinating
encouraging and inspiring about godwa
coming out
is he did not feel it necessary to lay
bare his soul his history or his love
life
for the world to see to pick over to go
oh
a public queer person let's examine no
you don't have any right to that
and in a Time
when queer people of all stripes are
under massive scrutiny
it is so important
to be reminded
that we do not owe
our lives and our information and our
identity
to other people
we definitely don't owe it to people who
mean us harm we don't even owe it to the
rest of the community
We Are Who We Are the extent to which we
are willing to share that is our
prerogative alone
some will be very very open and very
public but not everyone has to be
and to have a prominent example of
someone who is now out
but in the broadest possible sense the
way gotta is I think that has real
importance and real meaning because this
is a reminder
you don't have to bear your soul
in order to come out
it can feel like that regardless of how
much you come out but you are not
required to share everything he's not
required you're not required no one is
the choice and the control to whatever
extent you are able to hold on to should
remain with you
and if you choose to come out
it gets to be your terms your words or
at least it damn well should be
and that's why I can look at this
article and read about Judy godwa and
feel nothing but warmth
at reading this
and at the
tiny broad glimpse
that he saw fit to share with us
welcome
shirigatwa
you have been welcome in this community
for a very long time but
I want to do so formally
welcome to being queer obviously you
have been for some time
but welcome to owning the label
and to whatever Comfort level you have I
hope that having done this and said this
brings positivity and joy to your life
she said to someone who will never see
this video but I wanted to express my
appreciation because
this felt special
even within the realm of established
celebrities coming out this feels
special to me and I wanted to talk about
why
what are your thoughts on this whatever
they are
be polite and drop them down in the
comments and we will talk about it
patreon pays the bills and enables me to
do this as my living so that I can have
these talks with you about these things
but even if you can't support me that
way there's links to other things that I
do in the description but don't worry
too much about it
what I want you to remember
more than anything
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I am just running
the meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
shout out to the patrons who helped make
this possible in particular I want to
thank Robin Moore Zubin fulla goddess
Elida to rock the thing that goes doing
from the anime Ruth Oliver B solitary
pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen auntie
kate808 Becky Sparks ranabilox the
poodle Robin Powell t love Tracy scrapid
angry Casper Dave Hall and Rosalind
Bennett there's being able to hear me
try and pronounce your name plus a whole
bunch of other rewards on the patreon
you can check out the tears but um
if you're already on the list thank you
so much
[Music]